let's return to one of our top stories
and that's the Iranian president Ibrahim
raisy's visit to Venezuela we can now
speak to Abbas aslani who's a senior
research fellow at the center for Middle
East strategic studies he's in Tehran
joining us from there welcome to Al
Jazeera so what we've heard so far is
that a number of Accords have been
signed between the two presidents how
significant do you think this visit is
well Iran and Venezuela they have had
relations for long years but you know it
has been criticized here in the capital
that the previous government didn't pay
much attention to these bilateral
relations and that's why for about a
couple of years ago the level of volume
of the trade uh decreased to the you
know uh some hundred million dollars but
in the past years past couple of years
they have tried to increase it to the
three billion dollars and they aim to
increase it by as much as 20 billion
dollars but at the initial step it will
be about 10 billion so the current
Iranian Administration which has been
focusing on let's say having a good
relations with neighboring countries
Asian countries as well as those
friendly countries is also trying to
revive the capacity that it can find in
their relations with some Latin American
countries Inc including Venezuela right
right so let me ask you why now what do
we make of the timing of that then
uh you know in the aftermath of the you
know disappointment of let's about the
Revival of the nuclear dealer Iran has
been trying to resort to some
Alternatives in order to compensate you
know the shortages in its economic
relations uh so when Ron cannot have
good economic relations with the West
for sure it will you know shift toward
you know Eastern countries as well as
those countries who want to have good
relations with Iran but nothing is of
course the target of U.S sanctions
speaking of Iran and Venezuela as
whether as well as other countries uh in
in Latin America the EC will be visiting
but who do you think needs more here
you know the sanctions can be challenged
you know undermining the efforts by the
both sides in order to strengthen the
ties but it can be also a you know a
kind of opportunity for pushing these
two capitals and other countries who
have been under sanctions to cooperate
more so like what is happening between
Iran and Russia you know the scientist
has been pushing uh Mars Count to run in
order to expand Ties on economic field
so this is another issue you know
politically these two capitals also have
common grounds to work on and you know
the area that the uh or the region that
the Venezuela have been located in is
also of significance right and all this
to you know amounts to the importance of
the relations thank you so much
abbaslani for joining us from Tehran